the Joe Rogan experience you know
another thing I wanted to talk to you
about Michaels there's an article today
in the Atlantic which is really
interesting it's about technology it's
contact tracking technology and this
there's a real concern about this stuff
first of all the idea is great that if
you that this could free America from
quarantine so this is always the risk
right the risk is just give up a little
bit of your civil liberties give up a
little bit of your freedom and we're
gonna keep you safe and you know it
brings you to the old Benjamin Franklin
quote you know he who would give up
liberty for freedom deserves neither
neither nor Liberty for safety I'm sure
I've [ __ ] up that quote but this
technology is very interesting because
they're using it in South Korea and
they're using it in Singapore and I I
the the title of the article in the
Atlantic is the technology that could
free America from quarantine and it's
out today and they bring up this
conundrum I mean nobody wants to give up
civil liberties and civil liberties lost
or rarely regained and this is the real
concern here that if you do allow people
to track who you're in contact with and
make sure that ok you're testing
negative and you're in contact with
people that also test negative so you're
okay you're okay to travel now like this
is you know this is a very weird thing
and it gets us a very gray area how do
you feel about this I feel about this
way I I'm in general I I'm against that
sort of thing I like the idea of privacy
and that I do have a right to not be
tracked and you know you can't have
cameras in my home or my yard and so on
in general I think across the board
that's a good principle and it follows
the Constitution I think there are times
a national emergency like this of course
there's always the risk that you know
any auto crack and declare a national
emergency grab the power and never give
it back and I mentioned examples of this
before in Turkey say but the difference
here I think is you know we do have a
constitution we do have states rights we
do have courts that litigate these sorts
of things I could see a reasonable
measure being taken for let's say we're
do the following for six months until we
see what happens with this pandemic and
then once that's over then we're gonna
revert back now let's say the governor
or the president says well I'm not going
back well then you have courts then we
and you sue the state or you sue the
federal government for violations of
civil liberties and then you can get
them back right but you never happen
we've never got him back like what
happened to NSA when Edward Snowden
revealed how much tracking is actually
going on I mean that's never been
reversed I know I know
yeah I know who's buried I watched that
show yet when you had him on and oh boy
that was pretty disturbing very
disturbing it was also disturbing was
that now it's been proven that the Obama
administration lied they lied about what
you know is like metadata there's no
concern that was not just metadata that
they were they were able to read
people's emails right yes and you know
these this program was started in a bush
and so supposedly when Obama became
president it's like you know the the
transparent president so we're gonna
we're gonna stop doing that well that's
not the case so here's a good argument
for you know WikiLeaks and and the
Pentagon Papers that I recognize is
valuable that we wouldn't have known
that without Snowden or the or the
Pentagon Papers and you know it's good
to know what you know what your
government is up to and you know you
know in our mutual favourite subjects of
conspiracy theories you know we didn't
know about a lot of the things Kennedy
was doing in Johnson you know all the
way back to Eisenhower lying about the
Vietnam War for example until the
Pentagon Papers came out and then in the
90s the Church Committee on conspiracies
from the 70s a lot of those documents
were released and there was that that
business about the operation Northwoods
where kennedy administration people
brought to him this idea of a false flag
operation over cuba make it look like
the russians were harassing our aircraft
or our airports as an excuse to invading
Cuba or assassinating Castro and so on
it's like you know like when you had
Alex Jones on he talks about false flag
operations and most of us skeptics go oh
that's a bunch of nonsense and then you
read these documents that are revealed
in the in these release secret documents
like Wow okay so we did do that not just
that signed by the Joint Chiefs of Staff
Vito by Kennedy was like what the hell
are you doing you know and then finds
himself dead less than a year later
right hey you know in all the
shenanigans of American intelligent
agents manipulating elections in South
American you know democracies in the
mutt in the model of well he may be a
son of a [ __ ] but he's our son of a
[ __ ] Yeah right so we'd rather said we
would rather support the fascist
dictator rather than the communist
dictator it's like what are we doing
doing that anyway right well that's what
we do it's like wait a minute does the
public know about this did Congress
approve this no okay so you know this is
one reason people believe conspiracy
theories is because a lot of them are
true
[Applause]